sign this guy up to be a writer for film
theory but seriously does Anakin have a
point here or is he just blowin smoke
blowin smoke apparently but not in the
way that I anticipated
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that tries to find the dark
cloud in every silver lining or in this
case the dark side and every light side
of the force if I'm being honest I wish
the world could be as black and white as
the Star Wars universe makes it out to
be where you can tell the good guys are
good guys because they we're all white
and the bad guys are bad guys because
they're literally dressed all in black
but with the advent of the new trilogy
and the new millennium a lot of emphasis
has been placed on the grey that exists
between these two extremes because
rarely is reality so cut-and-dry but in
today's episode I want to do something
different I want to look back at those
older movies and show that things have
always been this way in the series that
despite George Lucas's not-so-subtle
costume choices from the original movies
and the blatant good versus evil
storylines that all of these films
purport to have the heroes aren't always
the heroes the stories frame amount to
be specifically I'm calling into
question the actions of the Jedi
now obviously I'm not the first person
to speculate about this in fact we've
already heard it straight from the mouth
of a Skywalker himself but maybe Anakin
here is on to something maybe when you
actually look at their own Jedi Order
their customs and especially the way
they train and recruit new Jedi things
don't look so good for the light side in
fact when you actually hold up the order
of the Jedi to objective scrutiny I
guarantee that you'll start seeing
Anakin's way of looking at things I
don't like sand
it's coarse and rough and irritating not
on that particular issue I started
thinking about this topic after another
famous Skywalker commented back in
Episode eight now that they're extinct
the Jedi are romanticize deified if you
strip away the myth and look at their
deeds and legacy the Jedi his failure
hypocrisy hubris well this kind of tea
spill coming from Luke was considered
pretty sacrilegious both by other
characters in the movie as well as the
audience watching Luke here has a point
if you examine the movies with a little
bit more scrutiny his criticisms aren't
exactly unfounded well there are
certainly examples of the Jedi doing
some pretty unsportsmanlike things to
innocent victims throughout old movies
like manipulating of these aren't the
droids you're looking for
stealing spaceships and crashing them or
just outright lying about their own
powers think it is time we informed the
Senate that our ability to use the force
is diminished if informed the Senate is
multiply our adversaries will the worst
thing about the Jedi is their
recruitment tactics and this is
foundational for the whole order the
entire Jedi institution is built on
years long training programs that
initiate new members if there's
something wrong at that base level it's
safe to say that the entire Jedi Order
is built on a rotten core and oh how
disturbingly rotten it is my friends
let's start at the beginning with the
recruit that we're all familiar with
Anakin Skywalker he's nine years old
when obi-wan and qui-gon jinn meet him
yet obi-wan remarks that Anakin
Skywalker is too old to be raised as a
Jedi no it will not be trained
no he's too old meaning that the Jedi
typically recruit at ages younger than
nine in fact as early as three years old
the Jedi identify force-sensitive
children and start training them watch
out mace windu capo be coming for you
well this might seem a little weird you
might also be thinking to yourself that
a lot of child athletes or children
entertainers start young to child models
gymnasts martial artists dancers all
typically start as young as preschool
that
said being a Jedi he is far from an
after-school program the Jedi organized
these pre initiate two clans who stay
together both night and day learning
eating and sleeping together like a good
old getaway camp except it's away from
their parents unlike a permanent basis
can you imagine a world where a parent
willingly ceases all contact with their
three-year-old and sends them away to a
compound full of adult men who spend all
day waggling their lightsabers I don't
think so
also unlike karate or tap dancing or any
of the other things parents obsessively
videotaped back in the 90s once you're
in the Jedi program you don't get to opt
out ever the only way a recruit can be
dismissed is with the approval of the
Jedi Order which obi-wan tells Anakin in
Episode two be mindful of your thoughts
Anakin they betray you you've made a
commitment to the Jedi Order a
commitment not easily broken until he
completes his training Anakin is in
every sense of the word an indentured
servant to the Jedi Order and a literal
prisoner of his training where we know
they're forced to do things like blind
combat with droids actually hurt people
as well as initiation tests that
canonically see children fighting and
simulated life-or-death scenarios to
test their Force abilities from a
functional standpoint the Jedi Order is
an irrevocable cult that lands somewhere
between an involuntary boot camp and
human trafficking so Anakin has a 19
year old has a commitment that can't be
broken one that he isn't allowed to
leave because when he was nine years old
he decided he wanted to be a space
wizard did he realize what he was giving
up no of course not he just saw really
cool force powers and laser swords what
child is gonna turn that down can a
nine-year-old really be expected to
commit to what basically amounts to an
entire childhood of indentured servitude
and fully understand the commitment that
they're about to make hey little kid
want to join our cult for the rest of
your life you'll get a lollipop and a
laser sword
okay mr. Jedi there's a reason that in
our real-world legal system a
nine-year-old isn't allowed to enter a
legally binding contract they're not
mentally ready and remember most of the
Jedi are recruited younger than we see
in Anakin Skywalker and this
commitment along with the complete
separation from these kids parents it
matters a lot if the Jedi cared at all
about the children under their tutelage
they would know that scientifically it
can be incredibly damaging to separate
young children from their parents at
least according to licensed clinical
social worker and child developmental
specialist Mary Wallace quote studies
have shown that if a child suddenly
loses a parent the child experiences
intense fear panic grief a combination
of sadness and loss depression
helplessness and hopelessness the child
has lost his lifeline and often his
sense of self the world and life becomes
disorganized and terrifying end quote
this is true not only in cases of
abandonment or death of a parent but
also true in cases of voluntary
separation this is because children
learn to trust the world through their
parental figures who provide a stable
base for young developing minds between
the ages of 0 and 7 severing that
connection at the age of three or even
the ripe old age of nine years old sets
children on a path to be emotionally
unstable
let's go figure is pretty darn ironic
since the Jedi aren't supposed to act on
emotions but I can't imagine how cutting
a child's lifeline and psychologically
scarring them for existence could
possibly backfire Master Skywalker
there are too many of them what are we
going to do truly wonderful the mind of
a child if you really believe that one
Yoda you'd be more concerned with taking
care of those children's mental health
making sure they don't wind up
permanently traumatized for life and
slaughtering a bunch of younglings
in fact Jedi care so little about the
relationship between parent and child
that in the prequel trilogy qui-gon and
obi-wan literally leave Anakin's mother
on Tatooine to continue living in
slavery in Episode one we're told that
they take Anakin but not his mother
because they don't have the money to buy
her freedom from Watteau is she free to
I tried to free your mother
what I wouldn't do it but that a decade
goes by without him ever following up at
no point during the 10-year period did
anyone bother to think hey maybe we
should you know go check on Anakin's
mother to make sure she's alive to see
her son become a Jedi or I don't know
maybe go back to buyer freedom since we
have the money to do it and we've won
the war and her son happens to be the
most powerful force user in history
Anakin is only able to return to her a
decade later an attack of the clones
against the wishes of his masters only
to find out that she's been in danger
for over a month kidnapped by the
sandpeople she's been gone a month
there's little hope she's laughs like
what makes the death of Anakin's mother
all the more tragic is that all of it
could have been prevented
he reaches her just as she's in her
dying breaths how do you arrive days or
even hours earlier his journey at
Tatooine might not have ended with him
having to bury her the only reason that
Anakin even knew about her is because he
could sense her suffering she's
suffering a pattern she is in pain hmm
didn't Yoda once say something about
suffering angry to hate hate leads to
suffering in this case it was ignorance
that led to suffering and suffering that
led to hate I hate them and I don't know
about you but it seems to me that if the
Jedi had bothered to take even the
smallest modicum of effort to keep the
family of their Padawan intact the
entire descent of Darth Vader from light
side to dark side because of his hate
pain suffering all of that could have
been pretty easily avoided the story of
Anakin's recruitment also illustrates a
larger point about how troubling the
recruitment tactics of the Jedi really
are aside from the obvious problems of
taking very young kids and signing him
up for decades-long obligations it'll be
very difficult for them to opt out of in
the future they're even dishonest in the
way that they signed these kids up in
the first place going back to that
example of Anakin when qui gonn is
deciding whether or not to take him on
as a recruit one of the things that he
needs to do is collect a blood sample so
they can measure his midi-chlorian count
now in the real world if you want a
blood sample from a child first of all
you don't get it because it's an
incredible invasion of privacy like if
you thought Coppa was worried about
child privacy well then you haven't met
HIPPA cappas much more powerful cousin
in the healthcare world that protects
patients from you know random coldly
collecting and analyzing their blood
samples so dis qui gonn asked his mom
for a sample does he explain what he's
doing to Anakin does he even sterilize
the needle let's watch what are you
doing checking your blood for infections
that's it no permission slip not even
verbal consent and then on top of all of
it he lies about the purpose of the test
in the first place you need an analysis
of this blood symbol I'm sending you
they need a midi-chlorian count I guess
you could try to argue that Anakin is
literally living in slavery and so he
and his mother are probably desperate to
get out of the situation and maybe that
makes it better but no you are so wrong
in fact the idea that qui gonn is
preying on people who have no rights and
no way to advocate for themselves makes
it that much worse you can even make a
case that the Jedi barely think of their
recruits as human has even the venerable
old obi-wan Kenobi everyone's favorite
Jedi describes Anakin like this why do I
sense we've picked up another pathetic
life-form that's pretty darn cold there
mister Kenobi old Ben I mean I can
understand calling Jar Jar Binks a
pathetic life-form but Anakin he's a boy
who's incredible podracing abilities one
of the ship parts you needed to get off
the desert planet you got yourself
stranded on I'd expect a little bit more
gratitude ya bum we all grew up watching
these movies thinking that the Jedi were
the heroes the movies outright frame
them to be the heroes but if you
actually look at how the Jedi become the
Jedi in the first place their legacy
isn't one of freedom and doing the right
thing it's about putting toddlers into
slavery deceiving their parents and then
brainwashing those little kids so they
become unquestioning members of their
little cult
sure we might be a little sad in episode
eight that there aren't any Jedi left
but believe me the children of the
galaxy should be thanking their lucky
stars that the likes of qui gong Yoda
and obi-wan aren't coming up and
knocking on their doors stealing them
away from the loving arms of their
families and this is just the tip of the
iceberg all of this all of this is
without even mentioning the lies of the
Jedi that happened throughout the
entirety of the series how their actions
their hubris their hypocrisy their
outright refusal to give up control
results in the dark side surging to
power and the downfall of the Galactic
Republic sure the Jedi are framed as
heroes and these stories if we turn off
our brains and just look at the wushi
woosh laser swords and cool magical
powers but if you stop
and actually analyze the plots of these
movies what is actually happening
between these characters and what causes
galaxy wide changes to take place you
start to see that it all boils down to
the actions of one group the Jedi and
ensure that you get that bail ripped off
your eyes about all things Jedi related
hit that subscribe button I know for a
fact that 50% of you aren't subscribed
but are still watching these theories so
let's change it help me get closer to
that diamond play button and help
yourself by ensuring that you're getting
a weekly dose of film theory goodness
smash that subscribe button slice it in
half with your laser sword force choke
it if you have to but always remember
especially today since I'm calling a
beloved fictional order of space wizards
evil that it's all just a theory a film
theory
[Music]
you